the boys episode 8 trailer breakdown and
reaction for us as we haven't even seen
the actual trailer for the last episode
of the boy season 2
homelander final scene theories this
comes from our friends over at
new rock stars who encourage us to
continue to react to their videos so
appreciate that guys i mean if you
haven't seen any of our boys reactions
there's a playlist i'll put in the
description box and pin comment
really been enjoying the show a lot
loving it
so much yeah i haven't seen the trailer
for it but you know i thought it'd be
fun to see what eric voss's
theories are on it because it's not an
actual spoiler unless he gets it right
just see that reaction come
in next time friday it'll be fun to see
if he gets it right at all
and yeah subscribe hit that notification
bell right now so you get notified when
our reaction for
the final episode of the boys will be up
which will probably be a two-parter
reaction because it's the finale so
it'll be a part one and part two so
just to prepare your minds for that
anywho let's see what he's got in store
for us today
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and the boys has been a
bloody diabolical horror show which we
have loved breaking down weekly in our
boys underground
after show to share our disgust and in
some cases
guilty pleasure the season 2 finale is
days away and its episode trailer hints
at
just enough of how this final hour will
wrap up the big mysteries we have had
this season i'm gonna break down this
footage and puzzle together other
remaining trailer footage to answer
who was behind the recent mind-blowing
twist ending and
major characters whose bloody insides we
might see next episode
spoiler morning before we continue and
here we go
wow this trailer shows you a lot
we are damn to serve and protect you the
promo picks up right where last episode
ended when the boys saw heads explode
and congresswoman newman's congressional
hearing on vaught
the victims included a train speedster
replacement shockwave former bot cso
jonah vogelbaum about to testify a
congressman
newman's aide lisa and at least 10
others
based on on-screen pops in audible pops
that we could hear over the screams
so quick rundown of the suspects many
believe cindy the escape suit experiment
from sage grove could be behind this
given her similar bod
bursting powers however her telekinesis
appears to be more
implosion-based and encompassing the
whole body
instead of just the head exploding
like she was locked up in sage grove
during the similar killing of rainer and
she likely would
not willingly cooperate with stormfront
or vaught like if she had been drugged
and forced to do this
actually seems like a bit too convenient
of the answer to the question conspiracy
theorist someone you might say
lee harvey oswald another suspect people
believe
could be the head of the scientology
inspired church of the collective
allister adana since shockwave was among
the kills
and alastair had made promises to
a-train to get him back into the seventh
but with a train still anti-vaught based
on this promo
we're even now holy why are you doing
this because i went back in
i remember that shot from the last trip
from the town on the early stream it
also be the extra i'd be calling
beardie it seems to be looking in the
general direction
that's freeze frame he's doing it with
his mind and he does have that
menacing golden tape color among the
blurry background faces
vibe but really let's be honest the most
logical culprit is
bot head stan edgar and yeah would be
the most eager to silence vogelbomb
and use a false flag suit terrorist
attack
one that he could blame on cindy as
grounds to stage a coup
for homelander and stormfront and take
over the us government and the white
house
the shot of the first american president
george washington getting sprayed with
blood
could have been a hint toward that plot
against the current white house of the
show and the opening
scene of the season showed edgar
negotiating with the secretary of
defense
over how exactly the seven will fit into
the chain of command
and if a last minute appointment of
homelander to the position of secretary
of defense would technically make
homelanders sixth in the line of
succession
according to the 25th amendment the
beginning homelander is making the first
in line
i mean let's be honest homelander isn't
very patient he seems like the kind of
[ __ ] who drives up on the shoulder to
merge five cards ahead
instead of doing it just now waiting
your turn a white house takeover seems
to be the coup
that rainer was referring to seconds
before her death
it's a cool from the inside
creepy nose speech looks very much like
a grimly composed speech
given right before or maybe right after
taking the oath of
office we are your heroes
we are here to serve you yeah that would
be crazy there which
you know i just bring up because every
time homelander says the word hero it
seems like it's either right before
or right after someone dies horribly you
are the real heroes
and you my friend are a true hero
[Music]
so if anyone in red white and blue ever
calls you a hero
even if they're carrying a captain
america's shield it's probably a good
idea to
run yeah i know i get excited anytime i
see the red white and blue but another
star that has me seeing red white and
blue that gets me excited is the star
blast flavor of bang energy bang guys
love you
you must be selling so much for bang
america every can of bang it's 16 ounces
that contains 300 milligrams they're
people who are just like buying more
bang because
i imagine it works because there were 20
different flavors to choose because uh
erin voss is so energetic
so they must be like there must be
something with the bang that's dude
check out bang on instagram you can get
25
off your order at bang energy so we're
the big one
want youtube ads
popularity drink right now yeah we need
more goodness supplements all kinds of
stuff to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video
get 25 eric is 10 percent more energetic
new rock stars 25 okay so after the
exploding heads attack episode 7
ended with butcher thinking about his
next move
what the [ __ ] do we do now and we
speculated that could be the boys
finally taking compound v themselves to
fight the seven head the head
but now judging from kamiko's rocket
launcher the battle plan appears to just
be
we can't just kill everyone that's
exactly what we're gonna do so the
mission here appears to be all around
ryan but it's not gonna go to
it's not gonna go according to plan
actually another shot and this trailer
shows home lander launching again with
this kid in tow we do see shots of becca
running in the woods
everywhere sadly escaping the compound
and arriving to the pawn shop
they took him damn ryan so
rescuing ryan for becca appears to be
butcher's call to action
yeah but uh i don't know how eager
butcher is gonna be the save right
everyone predicted that right effort
could win becca back despite running
back right halfway through a blindside
reenactment really the balance of power
has shifted starlight
and queen maeve appear to be working
alongside the boys
with a train continuing to help them
with intel and i'm assuming that finally
he would white house guy maybe there's
evidence that links stan edgar to the
exploding heads
whatever evidence rainer had right
before she died and we got confirmation
that the finale episode will feature a
battle between them
and stormfront she blows up this
airplane hangar in a clearing
maybe it's a rendezvous point for the
boys we also see homelanders touch down
to the similar
rural location maybe it gets there after
the fight is over like the season five
finale of supernatural
fighting no way
nico and starlight presumably stormfront
because another shout out to
zapskamiko off her really one of the
biggest lingering mysteries
is this shot of homelander from all the
way back last december
opening the very first teaser for the
second season
this particular shot has yet to appear
in the seven episodes of season two thus
far
so it must appear in the upcoming finale
episode and i am assuming it is going to
be a
key moment from the finale whose blood
is on homelander here who is he looking
down at some are suggesting this could
take place right after the head pops in
the congressional hearing which
of blood now is laying to rest the body
of jonah vogelbaum the closest thing to
a father figure he's ever had but
normally entertaining
that much blood over his face during the
massacre i guess the season no no he did
something
in the middle of it it's probably
probably at that press conference ever
we're seeing
jack's everyone up looking down and what
is that sadness love
grief whatever you call homelanders
emotion that is not rage or apathy
and we looked over and saw pokemon's
head pop feet away from him homelander
didn't look that horrified so one theory
is becca
who i'm not sure will survive this
season though i don't know he wouldn't
look that down
it's got to be like stormfront or ryan
that's gotta be one of two
this is either ryan or scott yeah of
course
the blood on homelanders face doesn't
necessarily belong to the person or
thing he's looking down at he does float
down the camera base is already covered
in blood
almost as if to say homelander left one
skirmish soaked in the blood from that
to then find the body of an unintended
victim of his destruction or
maybe it's a true bloodbath stormfront
kills becca and then ryan in that rage
snaps and kills stormfront which could
have sounded like
you know it should be even more powerful
[Music]
then snaps himself and kills ryan his
son or you know maybe homelander while
flying with ryan hugged him too hard and
he crushed them all over yeah
maybe ryan finally learns how to fly on
his own and homelander accidentally
flies through him
all kinds of horrifying directions this
could go i want you to comment down
below with your theory
what this is looking at in this shot and
if you really want to get to the boys
join me as we discuss theories about the
show on the rockstar's official discord
server all you got to do is become a
patron
at patreon.comrockstars subscribe to new
rockstars hit that notification bell
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to the boys
underground podcast feed wherever you
get your podcast thanks for watching
bye-bye
thank you senpai eric oh so much goodies
to
quickly dissect i feel like it's gonna
be ryan's
i think that look that specific look is
gonna be ryan there's just so much
that's
hinting at a couple of things one is
that
homelander is gonna have to do something
that's like a
big public massacre of something this
whole debate of going back and forth is
homeland good homelander good is
homeland or bad like even in the
public's eye
right they teased that one moment where
he was imagining just annihilating the
crowd i think that was episode
five there's gonna be something where he
does some type of public master
either at that place where he's giving
the speech because i love what eric was
saying about
however he says heroes he often commits
something very violent someone
dies usually when he brings up that word
or
you know you have that scene where he
takes ryan away from the army
it looked like he was trying to get like
keep him shielded away so
that i think they're gonna try to like
obtain him that they're not letting
homelander be daddy to him
that he's still like an asset right like
that's just the logical conclusion that
i would imagine that vaught would treat
the kid as
they kept him hidden from homelander for
a reason yeah they've spent time and
resources on this kid they clear and he
is the first naturally born super
powered person so you yeah they want an
eye on him they want they treat they
want ryan to
keep him as a product and i don't think
they want homelander and
stormfront you know being mommy and
daddy to them
my mind is going towards that it'll be
like a chaotic finale of
somehow you know butcher and
and becca will be there there'll be all
those people who will be there it's all
just chaos
and then i for some reason mine is
saying that stormfront
might kill ryan i just can't see why yet
i could draw some possible theories of
where the show would go with that of
somehow ryan is actually holding back
homelander from being the leader he's
capable of being
i don't know but at the same time i'm
thinking ryan is part of
uh vots you know major product maybe
some part of a bigger plan so i don't
know why she would do it
but i think both i think for sure
storefront has to be offed
too yeah yeah i don't know i'm i've
weirdly am preparing myself for a
big body count on the finale because i
feel like perhaps stormfront
ryan seems like he's in danger i feel
like in a weird way
starlight could be in danger especially
if they all line up in the same like
place again for some kind of big
nasty battle or something like that it
really makes me wonder too about uh
giancarlo esposito because
they've like teased him for so much of
the season and there's so much
questioning about like what kind of
power does this guy actually have over
these people the idea that he could be
the person at least behind the
exploding heads seems to make a whole
lot of sense
even though it's not the most obvious of
like a super
angle or something like that i don't
know i feel like that's actually a
pretty solid theory
more so than like cindy i thought the
the pointing out that cindy's power is
more based on
implosion and crushing than just simple
explosion
yeah i think that kind of debunks it
maybe it's not cindy i think in our our
review
actually i did bring up that i think it
might be uh stan it
makes the most sense that he wouldn't
want
this person testifying there's already
so much they're trying to do
to keep vaught in good public light
right now and the way they've been using
him in this specific season as sort of
this person who's even a threat
to homelander and who even has
authority over stormfront like the two
main baddies that
we see are homelander and stormfront but
i think the real ultimate baddie is
giancarlo esposito
and the power that he wields i mean we
saw that in
like early on in the season when
giancarlo
and homelander were talking with each
other that homelander was like backing
down
to him somehow it has to be part of his
plan i think that would elevate his
character
it would just make the most logical
sense any answer they gave me i'm gonna
accept you know i'm not gonna yeah like
what the hell
brands king you know yeah just go there
yeah i i feel like any answer uh will
suffice the whole thing with like a
train
working with them i i remembered seeing
i've been saying it's it's like the
first episode that we watched
i remembered seeing that brief moment in
the trailer when they're just talking
it's so
brief you don't even hear anything
amongst them okay so at some point a
train is gonna
ask um huey and starlight for help or go
to them to help them out in some way
right
and uh i'm just waiting for that i feel
like everyone's waiting for this moment
with homelander all bloody and i've been
waiting for the scene with eight
years i'm like that team really stood
out and i've been waiting for a train to
get there
to be a part of that side but it looks
like it's a little bit more later than
that because
he still has selfish motivations for it
it's not i'm turning good
it's i want to get back into the seven
as much as the marketing at first can
make it feel like oh they're giving away
too much i think they'd know to be you
know cleverly discreet or misleading at
certain moments too
yeah so that way you're not like feeling
like you got the whole thing spoiled
because at first i'm like oh man that's
way too much to show me
but then uh as uh as it kept going like
now they they know
they know they know to hide and surprise
even even if you watch like new
rockstars breakdown videos that they do
after the episode that they'll even be
surprised
it seems like they're in a position
especially with this show and especially
with the position to space it out week
by week that they would be able to
effectively tease and mislead us and
relish
in this process of us going god we have
just enough that we can draw all these
theories and not enough
yeah that we know until the episode gets
better so yeah now i'm just super
excited to see what's going to go down
all right guys well
thank you new rockstars for putting this
video together eric boss you killed it
once again
go get yourself a bang energy drink i am
assuming yes subscribe to new rockstars
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell keep a lookout our
reaction the two-parter will be up uh
sometime saturday or sunday and last but
not least
i'd like to give a shout out to a man
named jt because by the time he notices
this shout out he might have
already seen the boys i asked him
specifically if he's seen this season at
all yet and he's waiting
for all the episodes to come out so he
could just do one giant ass binge
then i'll get his opinion back to me i'm
excited to see
what he has to think about this this
show because personally we've been
loving it i hope you're not disappointed
buddy what i'm thinking is you know
you're you're gonna you can you're gonna
speed your way through this you're gonna
speed your you're gonna bench your way
through this just like just like
just like a just like an a train just
like the tr you're gonna then you're
gonna take
a deep dive into the thought process
for it while you're you're in your
television
set in your home land
sitting it's storms in front of your
parents
yeah or that with and and
uh you'll be drinking a a black noir uh
you know wine yeah elegantly yeah and
then you'll be showering your hair with
maveline
yeah and and uh and you'll be eagle the
archer
and while you're butchering me all right
jt you get the joke
[Music]
buddy